g dans grand nord un paquebot soviétique
heurte un iceberg débute naufrage
heureusement il n'y a aucune victime
attention sur les routes cet été les
chauffards seront sévèrement punis
le gouvernement est décidé à sévir comme
l'année dernière l'opposition malade de
son succès grogne à lui ds le secrétaire
général du rpr alain juppé est notre
invité
anniversaire du serment du jeu de paume
c'était il ya deux cents ans le
président mitterrand évoque les
événements
le chine la france bat largement la
bulgarie en basket c'est un bon début
pour un difficile championnat d'or
bonsoir vous êtes sur un paquebot vous
fait une croisière dans le grand nord
le paquebot a heurté un iceberg et
commence à couler s'il y avait des
violons vous vous croiriez revenus 72
ans en arrière sur le titanic
trêve de plaisanterie vous imaginez la
frayeur des passagers car l'histoire que
je vous raconte est vrai elle s'est
passée dans grand nord la nuit dernière
heureusement cette fois le bateau
soviétique qui transportait plus de 900
passagers et membres d'équipage ce
bateau n'a pas coulé il n'y a pas une
seule victime
récit de cette panique près de la banque
yves clot crespo ils en seront quittes
pour quelques engelures et beaucoup de
peur la croisière de ses 575 passagers
s'est arrêté là à 800 km au nord de la
norvège
ce matin tous dormait au neuvième jour
de lesieu péri
minuit passé de 30 minutes et un
sinistre crissement de la proue du
maxime gorki contre nice berg 325
passagers sont alors réveillés en
sursaut évacué avec quelques affaires
dans des canaux d'autres trouveront
asile sur la banquise
heureusement épaisse de plusieurs mètres
l'aube est froide
mais très vite les secours s'organisent
avec l'armée norvégienne le paquebot
bien que prôner tiendra le coup grâce à
ces caissons étanches tous les passagers
en majorité des retraités ouest allemand
s'en sortent indemnes
nous verrons
on n'a pas de nouvelles des passagers
mais on peut consommer étaient tous en
bonne santé à 6 aussi les deux français
quant au temps atlantique qu'il y a
vingt ans par et d'hambourg il devient
soviétique et baptisé maxime gorki en 74
ce bâtiment de croisière avait subi l'an
dernier une remise à neuf total il
devrait maintenant prendre le chemin des
îles fidji en norvège pour des
réparations dans un bassin de radoub les
vacances les plages la chaleur bien sûr
mais aussi les routes d'attention le
gouvernement va être sévère cet été pour
les chauffards l'avertissement a été
lancé tout à l'heure au cours d'une
réunion à matignon autour du premier
ministre michel rocard
explications daniel poirier les
automobilistes doivent apprendre la
conduite apaisée ce sont les propres
mots cet après-midi de michel rocard
l'opération menée avec des responsables
de sociétés automobiles et différents
médias va durer tout l'été dans quelques
jours on proposera tous les conducteurs
de signer un pacte de la route pas
d'alcool pas d'excès de vitesse
ne jamais oublier la ceinture de
sécurité ne jamais grillé un feu rouge
entretenir son véhicule être attentif
aux piétons et aux cyclistes des
engagements tout pour une plus grande
sécurité responsabilise les
automobilistes mais aussi réprimer comme
l'année dernière sur les routes et
forces de police seront plus nombreuses
les contrôles vont s'intensifier et les
permis pourront être suspendus
immédiatement en cas d'infraction grave
et les amendes payées immédiatement sur
les routes et bien c'est peut-être pour
demain
déjà en tout cas pour aujourd'hui dans
cinq départements c'est une expérience
de trois ou quatre mois
alors isabelle tu as s'est rendu dans un
de ses départements l'essonne
les automobilistes trouvent parfois que
les gendarmes pousse un peu
non seulement ils verbalisent mais en
plus depuis hier ils encaissent les
amendes
bonjour madame gendarmerie vous ne
partez pas votre ceinture de sécurité
vous avez 230 points à payer vous allez
choix de payer directement un donc faire
un versement immédiat ou bien de régler
plus tard avec un timbre amende
on voulait pas payer immédiatement banon
vous au noir avant ça va sauter c'est
pour ça m'arrive on s'adapte police
alors y'a pas de raisons sont maintenant
ou après bouvier
non pas leur donner du pognon puis
deuxièmement que la possibilité de les
faire sauter rares sont ceux qui paie
comptant seul intérêt du test
aujourd'hui se débarrasser rapidement
d'une contravention
en revanche dans quelques mois les
amendes ainsi acquitter devrait être
minoré pour les gendarmes
la tâche se complique ça amène des
gendarmes à manipuler de l'argent ce qui
n'était pas l'habitude de se faire donc
les auxiliaires du trésor
ban en face d'une expérimentation qui va
durer six mois et nous verrons après
quels sont les aménagements qui peuvent
être apportées absence de ceinture ou de
casque pour les cyclomotoristes seules
les infractions mineures sont concernés
payer moins mais tout de suite
dissuadera peut-être les fraudeurs
madame compte gouttes bull reste en
prison le juge a refusé tout à l'heure
au havre sa mise en liberté madame
boudoul est inculpé de complicité
d'homicide volontaire dans l'assassinât
de bruno da sac
elle nie pourtant avoir connu la victime
les avocats mobilisés après le drame de
vendredi dernier au moment de la
reconstitution du meurtre de la petite
céline vous vous en souvenez dans les
alpes de haute provence les avocats
avaient été molestés par la population
et l'ensemble des avocats a tenu
aujourd'hui à manifester sa solidarité
avec ses confrères pour que les droits
de l'homme pardon les droits de la
défense par don soit toujours préservé
quel que soit le crime
rémi roger le crâne en sang
métro et leclerc l'un des défenseurs des
meurtriers présumés n'a bu son salut
qu'à l'intervention musclée des
gendarmes
les autres avocats ont également été
molesté impossible de procéder à la
reconstitution du meurtre de la petite
céline en présence de cette foule
vengeresse
cet après midi le barreau de paris
auquel appartient m leclerc manifester
solennellement sa protestation devant de
par les agressions loin d'être créateur
de deshors l'avocat est au contraire une
agression blâmable devait dire à son
tour le procureur truche avant que
merial ezratty premier président de la
cour d'appel conclut il faut que la
justice s'exerce selon les voies légales
sinon c'est la porte ouverte à
l'arbitraire la porte ouverte à la
barbarie donc à toute notre sympathie
j'espère que en année du bicentenaire on
va commencer l'instruction civique pour
que les gens sachent ce qu'est la
démocratie ce que sont les rois de la
justice comment et pourquoi on juge un
homme comment il doit être défendu
comment on a le droit de condamner ou
comment on doit s'acquitter selon qu'il
ya des charges aussi bien à pas il faut
apprendre cela dès l'école aux enfants
et à quoi sert la dépense
après les incidents de vendredi le garde
des sceaux pierre arpaillange laissé
entendre que la terre céline pourrait
éventuellement être instruite ailleurs
qu'au tribunal de digne une fillette de
trois ans et demi ticket au pied par une
seringue cela s'est passé sur une plage
du cap d'ail dans les alpes-maritimes et
les parents portent plainte contre la
commune
alors bien sûr on imagine la frayeur des
parents face à cette blessure car les
seringues usagées porte les germes de
nombreuses maladies notamment le sida
mais que faire face à ces déchets qui
viennent de la mer et que même un
nettoyage systématique des plages ne
peut empêcher reportage de patrice volet
là on les a retrouvés sont au bord de
l'eau avec d'autres secours idéal de
produits qui sont pas biodégradables
cette fois ci ça venait des bateaux à
coup sûr dimanche le danger venait du
large johanna trois ans et demi ne s'est
pas méfié ses jeux d'enfant valtat ses
parents une immense inquiétude cette
seringue contenait tel un virus si oui
lequel
sida hépatite b les spécialistes se
veulent rassurants jeu tout dépend de la
quantité de virus présente et tout
dépend des traitements que subissent
cette seringue
si cette seringue est à l'air exposé au
soleil à la chaleur il est très
vraisemblable que la petite quantité de
virus qui s'y trouvent ci s'en est
trouvée a été inactivé la plage de lama
là un oasis de calme et de soleil
nettoyait en semaine par un employé
communal de 7 à 9
il ramasse bouteilles papiers mégots et
seringue justement est ce que
j'éprouvais beaucoup
j'allais jouer derrière problème pas de
nettoyage de samedi-dimanche à cap d'ail
on respecte le week-end alors bien sûr
la plage est un peu plus sales jusqu'au
lundi matin
mais à la mairie on n'estime pas devoir
faire plus et puis comment surveiller
chaque mètre carré
tout au long de la côte même qu'on met
toi un peu de merisier à ces règles peut
être là et même de nettoyage je pense
pas qu'on malheureusement la seule règle
pourrait être aperçu comme certains ici
souhaiterait un renforcement des
contrôles de police mais à dix jours des
vacances pas de véritable solution
johanna elle devra subir des examens
pendant un an avant d'être totalement
rassurés
il ya deux cents ans jour pour jour
c'était le ferment du jeu de paume
rappelez vous vos cours d'histoire ce
n'est pas le jour où mirabaud a dit nous
ne sortirons d'ici que par la force des
baïonnettes ça c'était trois jours plus
tard en revanche le serment du jeu de
paume c'est tout de même la véritable
naissance de l'assemblée nationale alors
pour cette occasion laurent fabius
président de l'assemblée française avait
invité à versailles dans la salle du jeu
de paume
les présidents des parlements des 12
pays de la communauté européenne
un bi centenaire célébré avec faste et
tout à l'heure le président de la
république était à versailles dans la
salle du jeu de paume pour cette
célébration
monsieur mitterrand a souligné que si en
france la démocratie date de 200 ans
la démocratie se conquiert jour après
jour et cela l'a amené à évoquer les
récents événements de chez observant le
mouvement du monde partout lève la même
espérance et cela nous ramène un péquin
place tiananmen
trois images une statue de la liberté
4 chis
1789 et ce jeune homme seul debout
devant les chars avez vous entendu ce
que criait la foule
on me l'a rapportée nous avons du pain
nous voulons des lois la vraie
révolution est en marche
les françois mitterrand était bien dans
la salle du jeu de paume à versailles
alors que tout à l'heure laurent fabius
je me suis trompé étaient à la sortie
sur le perron de l'assemblée nationale
en tout cas pour vous rafraîchir
rafraîchir la mémoire
si vous n'avez pas vraiment en tête ce
qui s'est passé le 20 juin 1789 et bien
voici un petit rappel historique nos
reporters vous le savez peuvent voyager
dans tous les coins de la planète
ils peuvent aussi c'est nouveau voyager
dans le temps bruno roger-petit est
remonté deux cents ans en arrière
reportage la porte close pour les
députés du tiers état
portes closes sur ordre du roi louis
saez a choisi la force des baïonnettes
il veut interdire les délibérations de
ces députés qui se réunissent en
assemblée nationale comme ils disent
depuis deux jours récriminations
indignation rien n'y fait les portes
restent closes
ulcéré les députés du tiers état ont
résolu de sigy malgré tout et n'importe
où
la salle du jeu de paume est libre à
cette heure on pourrait occuper
oui c'est une idée si sa région au japon
la caméra d'antenne 2 a suivi les
parlementaires jusque dans la salle du
jeu de paume décor insolite pour y
réunir ceux qui se proclament
d'assemblée nationale séance houleuse où
la décision royale visant à interdire
toute délibération des élus du tiers
état a été fustige puis les députés ont
repris leurs discussions
ils ont décidé de ne pas se séparer
avant d'avoir donné une constitution à
la france idées révolutionnaires
sur proposition de monsieur mounier
député de grenoble ils ont même prêté
serment
jean bailly le président de l'assemblée
nationale a d'ailleurs tenu être le
premier d'entre tous
jamais séparé de l'assemblée nationale
demeurait une irréelle
partout les circonstances l'exigeront
jusqu'à ce que la constitution du
royaume soit a permis sur des ponts d'or
inébranlable déjà les observateurs les
plus éclairés estime qu'il s'agit d'un
bouleversement de l'échiquier politique
le serment du jeu de paume
comme on devrait dire désormais pourrait
bien mettre un jour le roi louis saez en
échec les ce reportage exceptionnel a
été réalisé grâce aux images de lazard
iglesis l'auteur de la série que vous
avez vues sur antenne 2 l'été de la
révolte c'était avec notamment bernard
fresson dans le rôle de mirabaud vous
l'aurez reconnu conseil des ministres
qui se tenait exceptionnellement ce
mardi avec un projet de loi très
importants ils concernent le financement
des partis politiques le gouvernement
veut en finir avec l'hypocrisie de
l'argent qui pourrit les parties
explications laurent bousses y ait un
projet de loi présenté par pierre joxe
que michel rocard envisage de soumettre
au conseil constitutionnel et qui prend
en compte les dépenses et les recettes
nécessaires au financement de la vie
publique
côté recettes elles pourront être
publiques l'état financera les parties à
hauteur de leur représentativité ou
privés dans ce cas la limite des dons
autorisé sera de 50 mille francs par an
pour un particulier
cinq cent mille francs toujours par an
pour une entreprise le
étant rendues publiques et permettant
des déductions fiscales côté dépenses
les candidats aux présidentielles auront
droit à 120 millions de francs pour le
premier tour les candidats aux
législatives
huit cent mille francs et ce aux
élections locales et régionales ad somme
calculée en fonction du nombre
d'électeurs concernés une nouveauté on
parle de sanction en cas de dépassement
caractériser des plafonds fixés les
sanctions financières ou politiques
comme l'inégibilité pendant un an des
candidats fautive reste l'aministie des
délits liés au financement occulte des
campagnes électorales passées malgré les
interrogations et les critiques qu'elle
a déjà suscité l'amplitude de cette
amnistie n'est pas modifié elle
concernera toutes les infractions
commises jusqu'au 15 juin dernier tout y
compris celles qualifiées de crimes
comme les faux en écriture publique en
politique sachez encore que l'assemblée
siègerait probablement en session
extraordinaire début juillet c'est ce
qu'a indiqué le président du groupe
socialiste louis mermaz enfin
l'opposition ne déposera pas de motion
de censure sur le projet de loi
gouvernemental sur l'audiovisuel un
projet de loi qui institue une
présidence comme une antenne 2 fr3 la
grogne dans l'opposition apparemment
dimanche dernier l'opposition est sortie
victorieuse des élections européennes
mais ce n'est pas si simple exemple à
l'udf le parti de valéry giscard
d'estaing françois léotard a donné un
coup de pied dans la fourmilière ce
matin il veut réformer l'udf et il
s'attaque aussi bien à giscard cas
chirac
véronique syntonisent je reconstruis
tueur construit nous reconstruisons 48
heures après les succès de giscard aux
européennes la reconstruction fait rage
au sein de la famille du df sur le fond
giscardien rénovateurs tout le monde au
p r est d'accord quant à savoir qui
dirigera le chantier c'est une autre
affaire ça nous prend au sein du parti
républicain et de toute l'opposition
mais c'est valéry giscard d'estaing au
grenier alors je crois que la rénovation
c'est l'idée d'une opposition unie donc
avec tout le monde
pour le papa
faut faire très vite organiser
l'opposition en solitaire demande quand
même la mise au placard de giscard
françois léotard il n'y a pas de
problème
il l'a confié au point pour lui chirac
et giscard doivent être mis hors course
et le président du parti républicain
ouvre grand les bras aux centristes et
aux rénovateurs les frères ennemis
d'hier
nous voulons nous inscrire dans une
logique d'ouverture vers l'ensemble des
autres formations de l'opposition
construire dans les années qui viennent
le plus vite possible une vaste
formation qui puisse servir de point
d'équilibré au parti socialiste françois
lyotard c'est que le rpr est hostile à
cette formation unique mais il prend
date
dans l'immédiat il se libère de la
tutelle de giscard dans l'entreprise de
la rénovation
il ne veut pas être ouvrier de la
dernière heure avec nous le numéro deux
de la liste giscard pour ces élections
européennes qui est aussi secrétaire
général du rpr c'est alain juppé bonsoir
monsieur juppé bonsoir alors valéry
giscard d'estaing contesté à l'udf c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire on a
l'impression aussi que jacques chirac
ait contesté non seulement dans son
parti au rpr mais par toute l'opposition
mais moi je ne vais pas ajouter mon
petit couac à cette cacophonie et je ne
voudrais surtout pas à me laisser voler
notre victoire
ce qui est important nous sommes à deux
jours à peine du scrutin européen
c'est ce qui s'est passé dimanche et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dimanche et
bien tout simplement nous avons briser
cette spirale d'échecs dont parlait
certains nous avons battu très largement
mieux que nous pensions les socialistes
et c'est je crois cela qui est important
pour redonner un dynamisme à
l'opposition pour concrétiser l'union
que nous avions déjà réalisé en partie
pour cette élection européenne voile
important tout le reste c'est une
agitation un peu prématuré vous avez
quand même j'ai parlé cacophonie ça veut
dire que l'union est drôlement
nécessaire absolument c'est bien pour ça
que je veux travailler à l'union et de
pas je le répète participer à toutes ces
turbulences prématuré on nous parle des
élections présidentielles soyons sérieux
ou cinq minutes soyons cédant six ans
ce mitterrand est en bonne santé c'est
de le rester donc ya pas urgence
on verra bien ce qui se passera dans les
années qui viennent pour l'instant
travaillons à l'union travaillons à
proposer un vrai projet aux français
c'est ce que le rpr souhaite et c'est ce
qu'il propose à ses partenaires
non mr roussey il ya toujours des
leaders tout de même donc est ce que par
exemple jacques chirac souhaite être le
leader de l'opposition
et vous l'avez entendu dire ça ce que
souhaite jacques chirac sait que l'union
se fasse et que le rpr se réforment
relance son action et participe à
l'union de l'opposition c'est très
exactement ce que nous allons faire
jeudi prochain nous avons préparé
proposé présenter un plan très ambitieux
je crois qui comporte toute une série de
dispositions des groupes de travail
permettant de préparer parce que ça se
prépare
des états généraux de l'opposition pour
l'année prochaine un intergroupe à
l'assemblée nationale une coordination
des formations politiques de
l'opposition et un système de primaires
à la française pour les élections
présidentielles ça c'est du concret
plutôt que de chercher à savoir si un
chef ou pas de chef un grand chef un
petit chef
et si on travaille là dessus vous savez
la meilleure manière de ressusciter la
querelle des chefs c'est d'en parler
président du parti républicain ouvre
grand les bras aux centristes et aux
rénovateurs les frères ennemis d'hier
nous voulons nous inscrire dans une
logique d'ouverture vers l'ensemble des
autres formations de l'opposition
construire dans les années qui viennent
le plus vite possible une vaste
formation qui puisse servir de point
d'équilibré au parti socialiste françois
lyotard c'est que le rpr est hostile à
cette formation unique mais il prend
date
dans l'immédiat il se libère de la
tutelle de giscard dans l'entreprise de
la rénovation
il ne veut pas être ouvrier de la
dernière heure avec nous le numéro deux
de la liste
giscard pour ces élections européennes
qui est aussi secrétaire général du rpr
c'est alain juppé bonsoir monsieur juppé
conçoit alors valéry giscard d'estaing
contesté à l'udf c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire on a l'impression aussi que
jacques chirac ait contesté non
seulement dans son parti au rpr mais par
toute l'opposition
mais moi je ne vais pas ajouter mon
petit couac à cette cacophonie et je ne
voudrais surtout pas me laisser voler
notre victoire
ce qui est important nous sommes à deux
jours à peine du scrutin européen
c'est ce qui s'est passé dimanche et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dimanche et
bien tout simplement nous avons briser
cette spirale d'échecs dont parlait
certains nous avons battu très largement
mieux que nous pensions les socialistes
et c'est je crois cela qui est important
pour redonner un dynamisme par
l'opposition pour concrétiser l'union
que nous avions déjà réalisé en partie
pour cette élection européenne voilà
l'important tout le reste c'est une
agitation un peu prématuré vous avez
quand même fait par les claques fenillat
veut dire que l'union elle est drôlement
décès faire absolument c'est bien pour
ça que je veux travailler à l'union et
de pas je le répète participer à toutes
ces turbulences prématuré on nous parle
des élections présidentielles soyons
sérieux cinq minutes soit or c'est dans
six ans ce mitterrand est en bonne santé
et je dis c'est de le rester tant qu'il
ya pas urgence
on verra bien ce qui se passera dans les
années qui viennent pour l'instant
travaillons à l'union travaillons à
proposer un vrai projet aux français
c'est ce que le rpr souhaite et c'est ce
qu'il propose à ses partenaires
non merci
des leaders tout de même donc est ce que
par exemple jacques chirac souhaite être
le leader de l'opposition
mais vous l'avez entendu dire ça ce que
souhaite jacques chirac sait que l'union
se fasse et que le rpr se réforment
relance en action et participe à l'union
de l'opposition c'est très exactement ce
que nous allons faire jeudi prochain
nous avons préparé proposé présenter un
plan très ambitieux je crois qui
comporte toute une série de dispositions
des groupes de travail permettant de
préparer parce que ça se prépare
des états généraux de l'opposition pour
l'année prochaine un intergroupe à
l'assemblée nationale une coordination
des formations politiques de
l'opposition et un système de primaires
à la française pour les élections
présidentielles ça c'est du concret et
plutôt que de chercher à savoir si un
chef ou pas de chef un grand chef un
petit chef
et si on travaille est si vous savez la
meilleure manière de ressusciter la
querelle des chefs c'est d'en parler
l'enjeu c'est alain juppé jeudi à votre
conseil national vous allez proposer la
création de courants ou rpr alors le rpr
c'est encore un parti où c'est déjà une
nébuleuse
ça n'a jamais été un parti et je
souhaite que ça devienne un
rassemblement aussi large que possible
je ne vais pas à proprement parler
proposé l'organisation de courant je
vais simplement proposé que désormais
dans nos instances nationales tout ça
est un peu technique je le reconnais on
puisse voter à la proportionnelle pour
que chaque sensibilités puissent
s'exprimer sensibilité inter dans les
repères et je le souhaite demain
sensibilité externe
si un certain nombre de gens aujourd'hui
dans l'opposition souhaitent exprimer
leur personnalité tout en étant d'accord
sur l'essentiel avec ce que nous
exprimons mais ils sont les bienvenus
chez nous voilà ce que veut devenir leur
père retrouvé ses sources populaires
retrouve un message humaniste et de ce
point de vue ce qu'a dit michel noir
hier soir à l'heure de vérité m'a paru
frappé au coin du bon sens et ouvrir
largement ses portes à tous ceux qui
souhaitent le rejoindre
vous dites que vous avez gagné dimanche
et pourtant vous ne déposez pas de
motion de censure quand gouvernement
rocard sur son 49,3 là vous êtes devenus
frileux
excusez vous rajoute pas le lien entre
les deux nous n'avons pas déposé deux
motions de censure d'abord après en
avoir parlé entre nous il ya eu une
réunion de l'udf de l'ue décès et du rpr
il nous est apparu que ce texte ne
méritait pas cet excès d'honneur car il
a deux articles je crois qu'ils sont
relativement limités et puis ensuite on
ed
elle passe je puis dire la motion de
censure à tout moment si nous l'avions
fait on nous aurait opposé on ne saurait
reprocher d'être un petit peu
systématiques
nous dirons tout le mal que nous pensons
de sa disposition vous diront également
tout le mal que nous sommes devenus nous
pensions de la manière dont le pouvoir
essaye de remettre la main sur un
certain nombre de médium et il nous est
apparu nécessaire de faire une motion de
censure alors que didier réty content de
la prestation michel noir hier à l'heure
de vérité jacques chirac aussi on est
très contents que nous sommes tous
contents d'abord parce que michel noir
affirmé sa volonté de situer son action
politique au sein du rpr très bien moi
je me suis trouvé en très large accord
avec lui et en particulier parce qu'il a
dit qu'il fallait donner davantage à la
politique une dimension humaine je
dirais presque humaniste c'est vrai que
c'est un point sur lequel nous avons
encore des progrès à faire
en revanche si vous voyez que je ne te
laisse pas la langue de bois j'ai un
point de désaccord avec lui lorsqu'il
parle de la division de l'opposition
dimanche dernier je trouve qu'on ne peut
pas en faire porter la responsabilité à
parts égales sur tout le monde nous nous
avons voulu l'union on avait excommunié
personne et donc j'ai le sentiment que
nous n'avons rien à nous reprocher
d'ailleurs apparemment ce que nos
électeurs ont bien compris merci alain
juppé on va parler de chiffres
maintenant il s'agit l'économie voyons
les nouvelles importantes dans ce
domaine de ce mardi
et l'on reparle de la hausse des prix
éric perrin pose des prix de 0 4% en mai
soit une progression globale de 3,7 pour
cent pour l'année en cours
ce chiffre légèrement meilleur que celui
d'avril et malgré tout supérieurs aux
prévisions
toutefois le ministère de l'économie et
des finances table sur une amélioration
pour les mois à venir
le différentiel des relations avec les
autres pays est d'ailleurs favorable à
la france
après peugeot et citroën hier renault
décide à son tour d'augmenter ses tarifs
de 1,8 pour cent à partir du 1er juillet
prochain
les constructeurs automobiles français
n'ont donc pas suivi les conseils du
ministre des finances pierre bérégovoy
qui leur demandait de modérés voire de
reporter ses os ses augmentations
pèseront légèrement dans l' indice des
prix du mois de juillet
les laïcs à la tête de la banque du
vatican le saint siège a nommé
aujourd'hui au conseil de direction des
banquiers italiens suisses espagnols
ouest allemand a expliqué un homme
d'affaires américain
ces nominations entre dans le cadre de
la vaste réforme mise en place à la
suite du scandale de la banque
ambrosiano qui s'étaient conclues par la
mise à l'écart de monseigneur marching
pousse la crise politique en grèce dans
ce pays si la crise politique n'est
jamais très loin de la tragédie grecque
bien sûr dimanche dernier vous le savez
il y avait aussi des élections
législatives en grèce en plus des
européennes
le socialiste papandréou les a perdus le
conservateur mitsotakis a été chargé de
former le gouvernement
michel mompontet voici un homme qui
semble ce soir promis au rôle de héros
malheureux d'une tragédie grecque
constantin mitsotakis a pourtant presque
tout pour être le triomphateur des
législatives de dimanche mais il lui
manque que le principal des atouts il
n'a pas la majorité à l'assemblée
il lui manque sept sièges mitsotakis ne
peut donc former un gouvernement de
coalition et il a pour cela trois jours
le pari semble impossible il lui faut
s'allier
mais avec qui les communistes ont déjà
refusé c'eût été une alliance
impardonnable pour les électeurs
respectives des deux parties il ne lui
reste donc plus qu'un parti face à lui
pour une alliance
le parti socialiste de monsieur
papandréou mais papandréou et ses
scandales de coeur le parti socialiste
grec et ses scandales financiers
l'opinion publique n'en veut plus ce
soir la grèce semble bien être devenue
ingouvernable en pologne solidarité qui
est sorti grand vainqueur des élections
législatives solidarité juge toutefois
prématurée une entrée au gouvernement
c'est ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
le porte parole du syndicat en union
soviétique les troubles s'étendent en
asie centrale après l'ouzbékistan le
kazakhstan il y a eu le week-end dernier
trois morts et 53 blessés
et puis la chine un mois après
l'instauration de la loi martiale
la situation est loin d'être réglée les
condamnations continuent à pleuvoir
cependant les trois condamnés à mort de
shanghai n'ont pas encore été exécuté
les arrestations se poursuivent et
notamment dans les trains c'est là que
les fautifs entre guillemets bien sûr
sont souvent
retrouvez nos envoyés spéciaux se sont
rendus de shanghai à canton dans le
train un voyage long et épique mais qui
donne bien la tonalité du climat en
chine
reportage difficile en ce moment pour
des journalistes de voyager en chine et
cassettes vidéos sont frappés par la
police
par le train reste le moyen de transport
le plus sûr
nous n'avons pas non plus d'interprète
il est dangereux en ce moment tous les
chinois de se montrer avec des étrangers
les appels à la dénonciation sont lancés
à la télévision chinoise est placardée
sur les murs
35 heures de voyage pour 1800 km entre
canton et shanghai
voyage dans la tourmente de la chasse au
fond très révolutionnaire
le train est bondé
entre les chinois surtout à l'heure
guinée par le d'abord des matches à fond
de déclin chacun a sa version
ces bilans entre quatre et dix mille
morts
domtar est aussi l'heure des règlements
de france commence dans ce coin
nous avons des étudiants peut-être
recherché par la police il y a eu trente
deux arrestations ces dernières heures
mais des leaders importants sont
toujours en fuite
l'étudiant adot semble-t-il à trajet à
multiples arrêts il s'arrête dans de
petites gares de campagne attendant le
prochain train et repartent
histoire de brouiller les pistes on
notera un nouveau la joie donc on va
rester sur elles des familles inquiètes
rejoignent tous ces chandails pour avoir
des nouvelles de leurs enfants c'est
idiot
même si l'europe est à la prudence
ils ne sont pas être filmé il tente de
retrouver un chandail une jeune fille
professeur dont il n'a aucune nouvelle
depuis le 20 mai depuis trois ans
écrivait deux fois par semaine je ne
pense pas qu'elle participe activement à
la politique
140 boucle sud je ne sais pas exactement
elle n'aura pas dans ces lettres vous
savez elle fait très attention
j'ai trop de choses et à vouvry tue
cochon noir de ma réponse non européens
à la recherche de ces dames ne change
des chinois à dissimuler la radio si la
répression et on prend ce moment en tout
cas
la situation à shanghai demeure
incertaine
nous parlions du bicentenaire tout à
l'heure avec l'anniversaire du serment
du jeu de paume on en parle encore avec
la restauration des invalides le dôme a
retrouvé ses statuts et sa dorures ce
ces invalides date de la fin du xviie
siècle mais les statuts avaient disparu
en 1793 elles ont été remises
aujourd'hui il y à la fois la charité
l'espérance et la religion quant au dôme
il a été redorée pour l'occasion où vit
sur du bicentenaire pour la quatrième
fois en deux siècles
cela coûte cher mais c'est très beau bon
début sur les basketteurs français aux
championnats d'europe à zagreb en
yougoslavie pour leur premier match les
français ont battu la bulgarie largement
c'est de bonne augure
jean ma mère voici le héros du match
richard dacoury trente deux pointes créé
à lui tout seul sur les 109 du total pas
mal dacoury a été de tous les bons goûts
il a été le moteur et le dynamiseur de
cette équipe de france
d'une adresse assez exceptionnels il
s'est imposé par son sens tactique mais
aussi par sa grosse présence physique
sous les paniers enfin phénomène assez
rare un tel niveau de compétition il a
inscrit cinq paniers à trois points
mais cet après midi c'est toute l'équipe
de france qui a mis sous l'éteignoir une
équipe de bulgarie assez maladroite 30
points d'écart à la mi-temps une marche
que les français ont maintenu tout au
long de la rencontre sans difficulté
apparente
à l'exemple de ce panier de cham les
français de façon assez inattendue ont
donc fort bien entamé ces championnats
d'europe
109 à 78 corps final 33 points d'avance
c'est historique
mais demain les affaires risquent fort
d'être plus compliqué face à la grèce
championne d'europe en titre
et je vous rappelle que vous pourrez
suivre les demi finales et la finale de
ce championnat d'europe de basket samedi
et dimanche sur antenne 2 bien sûr c'est
la chaîne du basket
voilà avant de terminer complètement
cette édition du journal laissez moi
vous donner les résultats du tiercé
l'arrivée a eu lieu il ya quelques
minutes à vincennes voici la l'ordre
d'arrivée 11/06/10 je crois que nous
n'avons pas encore les rapports de ce
tiercé qui vient de se courir à tout de
suite la météo c'est sophie davant qui
annonce encore du soleil dernier journal
henri sannier vers 23h30
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain 20
heures
non